please explain explain why the
Israelites were allowed to kill all the
people in the promised land I know God
is a just God how can I explain to my
children why God permitted them to be
killed did they deserve to live in the
first place that was a theocracy at this
time God was in charge and I don't
question whatever God wants to do would
you say Amen to that
now there are many who stumble over that
the Commandments say thou shalt not kill
and yet Israel was told to wipe out
certain people who had gone before God
in judgment and now the Judgment of God
was to be executed upon them and in
order to establish respect for his
people God gave them victory in battle
there's one text that might help you I
know it helped me when I found it it's
Jeremiah 51 and verse 20. there God said
of Israel you are my battle ax
I will use you to destroy Wicked Nations
and the fear of Israel spread throughout
the land and the fear of God and so God
chose this course and he was in charge
and they were used as executioners in
God's system of judgment
please Pastor tell me where were Satan
when God made this world or creation
weak
I don't know exactly he was somewhere
there was a time when he was in heaven
he was kicked out and could no longer go
up there and not until Christ died was
he born from visiting other planets
that's why Revelation 12 says after the
death of Our Lord therefore Rejoice ye
Heavens plural but woe to the
inhabitants of the earth and of the sea
for the devil has come down unto you
having great wrath because he knew it
that he hath but a short time only now
is he circumscribed before then he went
around trying to spread his filth
amongst the Stars you get an indication
of that in Job chapter 1 verse 1 and up
next please Pastor Brooks is it possible
to be a Christian without being a member
of a particular religion or group well
you can't be a Christian without being a
member of a particular religion because
Christianity is a religion
and then why would you want to be
I was recently asked by a lady whom I'd
never seen if I would baptize her a
Caucasian lady she came to our church
and I said well of course we'll do it
and when we got down to it she wanted to
be baptized but didn't want to join the
church I said I don't know how to do
that baptism is the door to the Lord's
Church would you say amen amen and now
why would a person want to be baptized
and not belong to the Lord's church when
he said he's coming for a church not
having spot or wrinkle or any such thing
the Lord has a church and it ought to be
a pleasure and it is a pleasure to
belong to it
are we going to grow old and have babies
when we get to heaven
Jesus and they wanted to know suppose a
man marries a lady and he dies and then
she marries his brother and he dies
until seven brothers marry the same
woman when they get to heaven whose wife
is she going to be find this in Matthew
chapter 22 and Jesus said in verse 29
you do ear not knowing the scriptures
for in heaven thou neither be marriage
nor given in marriage but we're going to
be like the angels now please don't
think I'm being facetious when I say the
main thing to do is to make sure you get
to heaven
don't don't worry about all that up
there's one thing I know David said that
when I awake I shall be satisfied
whatever God's plan is it's going to be
better than Hell and Hell is going to be
down here
Pastor you mean new testament Christians
are supposed to keep old Moses law
it never fails people refer to Moses as
all Moses as though he were a bad fellow
does anyone know where Moses is tonight
is where
you're trying to get where Moses is
would you say Amen I'll tell you
now Jesus quoted Moses and Jesus said if
you had believed Moses you would have
believed me you want to read that fine
John 5 46 and 47 but Jesus said how can
you believe me if you didn't believe him
this idea of dispensations has man me
and this idea that you're not supposed
to believe the Old Testament is utterly
ridiculous when Jesus was here there was
only one Testament and that was the old
the first book of the New Testament was
written 22 years about 22 years after
the extension and it was The Book of
Mark so if you believe the scriptures at
all when Christ was here that's all you
had and it was good enough for him the
Bible says he began with Moses and all
the prophets and explained unto the
people the things the scripture said
concerning himself that was on the road
to Emmaus next please sir is it a sin
for a woman to put on pants please
explain Deuteronomy 22 5. we often get
this text Deuteronomy 22 5 says that a
woman shouldn't wear that which
pertaineth to a man neither should a man
put on a woman's garment for whoever
does it is an Abomination unto the Lord
and there is some who feel that if a
lady puts on slacks she is committing a
sin in the first place I don't believe
that in the days when this was written
neither men nor women wore pets they all
wore robes would somebody say Amen and
so what God has always been interested
in is that you be able to distinguish
between the sectors
God has always both Old and New
Testament utterly condemned
homosexuality and the gay lifestyle and
God does not approve of men trying to be
women nor of women trying to be men
now when it comes to our culture there
are places where it's inappropriate to
wear pants when you come to worship it's
better and if you have on pants tonight
you're just as welcome as you can be but
it's better to wear something else to be
a little more uh formal when you worship
God but if you're going to ride a
bicycle I want to tell you pants beat
skirts
and if you're going to climb a mountain
you need bandsaw especially if there's a
man coming up after you
pastor we have been told that if we have
the Holy Ghost we don't need to obey the
law please explain I hope you heard that
we preached on God's law last night and
someone says we've been told that if you
had a holy ghost you don't need to obey
the law ladies and gentlemen I wish I
had time to read all of this to you but
I want you to listen to this I'm reading
from the book of Acts chapter 5 and I'm
reading verse 32 this is the word of God
listen please Acts chapter 5 and verse
32 and we are his Witnesses of these
things and so is also the Holy Ghost
whom God hath given to them that obey
him is that clear
to whom is the Holy Ghost given
you can't even have the Holy Ghost
without obedience or at least the
willingness to obey next please
Pastor in last night's sermon you said
God's law existed in heaven before
creation and that God's law is The Ten
Commandments since the fourth and fifth
commandment seem to relate strictly to
mankind as does most of the others as
well how would you state God's law in
heaven before creation somebody's very
provocative and profound in their
thinking I I think all you have to do is
adapt it to the culture of Heaven
when the Bible says Thou shalt not kill
Thou shalt not kill others there was war
in heaven and Satan would have killed if
you could have all of these things
applied on a particular plane to
whatever culture God was addressing when
the law was given to man it pertained
especially to man's relationship with
God the first four Commandments and
man's relationship with his fellow man
the last six
most preachers just take one text and
close the Bibles and talk about an hour
why do you move around in the Bible so
much
well let me find it now you give me a
moment I think I can
I got it
somebody said most preachers take one
text close their Bible and talk for
about an hour why do you move around in
the Bible so much I think it's a
question of whether you want to hear
most from man or from God
you want to hear what God says in the
first place the Bible does not
contradict itself the Bible is inspired
by one Holy Spirit there's no reason for
him to contradict himself and so if it
appears to be a contradiction the
problem is not with the Bible but with
your understanding of it now let me read
to you from chapter 28 of Isaiah verse 9
Whom Shall he teach knowledge and Whom
Shall he make to understand Doctrine
them that are weaned from the milk and
drawn from the breasts verse 10 for
precept must be upon precept precept
upon precept line upon line line upon
line here a little and there a little
would you say Amen out there church
don't ever worry if I move around in the
Bible it's when I start moving out of it
that you ought to be concerned what do
you say
it's all the word of God
Pastor why is it if you want to obey you
are called a legalist please explain
well yes we talk about the Ten
Commandments and when you start talking
about rules and Commandments people
think uh in legal terms and they have a
disparaging word legalist
well I asked this question are you a
legalist if you stop at a red light
God answer me are you
well of course not
in order for society to function
smoothly it is necessary to have some
rules you are not a legalist for
following rules without it there'd be
more wrecks in Phoenix than you could
keep a count off
Now ladies and gentlemen God told us to
obey his Commandments
you are not a legalist if you do that
a legalist is one now this is very
technical so don't miss it a legalist is
one who thinks he can earn salvation by
obeying rules have you got it
a legalist is a person who believes in
righteousness by works
a legalist is one who thinks that by
obeying a set of rules he earns brownie
points with the Lord
that is not the life of an obedient
Christian
a pear tree doesn't produce pears to
prove it's a pear tree
a pear tree produces past because it is
a pear tree
when we are Christians and we start with
Jesus and not the Commandments
when we are Christians obedience is the
fruit of a Christian Life it is simply
the lifestyle of a person who loves the
Lord and lives by faith that person is
not a legalist he's not trying to earn
anything he knows that Jesus Paid It All
next please
Pastor why does a faithful church-going
man that has given his life to Jesus
Christ have such a negative attitude all
the time he never even Smiles I know
this man doesn't have in Christ in your
life make you happy
I'm I'm sincerely glad that you don't
put names on these cards so nobody can
assume I'm talking at anyone but listen
Jesus came that you might have joy would
somebody say Amen
he came that your joy might be full now
I don't know how it's possible to have
the joy and peace that Jesus came to
give you and not reflected in your life
and in your countenance I cannot make
sense of this it is totally incongruous
for a person to call himself a Christian
and be negative all the time
Christianity is positive we are to
Rejoice that our sins are gone Rejoice
that we know Jesus Rejoice that we
belong to him
and a person who chose the church and is
always a sour push
this honors the Lord so my dear brother
if you are listening
start
smiling
start acting like a Christian if you are
redeemed act like you are redeemed
if you are happy inside notify your face
get your chin up off the ground and
spread a little sunshine
pastor this comes from a young person
that's here tonight parents tell their
children they can't go to the movies
because it's bad or wrong yet they rent
the same movies and watch them at home
what's the difference what's wrong with
the theater I want to tell you first of
all that there are many many many many
many many things you shouldn't look at
in your home
but let me tell you the key and I hope
you'll always remember this I used to go
I think I mentioned this I used to spend
a lot of time on College and Academy
campuses and young people would always
want to know what's wrong with this and
what's wrong with that that is not the
way to serve the Lord
what you want to do is to become
converted and when you are converting
the Bible says oh things are passed away
behold all things are become new you
have new tastes new desires new
pleasures and if you ever get converted
the Holy Spirit Will reside in you and
when you turn on something that you
shouldn't look at the Holy Ghost will
tell you
you don't need some preacher telling you
everything that's right or wrong and
parents if you want your children to be
good set them an example
next please
Mr evangelist after hearing the plain
truth put so simply why do men teach
that the law of God is done away with
well I I I start to say I don't know I
think I do and and we'll give you at
least one answer to that in tonight's
sermon but in Luke 16 what did I say
and verse 17. now I'm a type of person
when I hear the word of the Lord I want
it to stick
and when God speaks that settles it the
Bible says in Luke 16 17 it is easier
for heaven and earth to pass than for
one Tittle of the law to fail
now if you find me somebody who can
destroy Heaven and Earth then maybe I'll
listen to them when they say the law is
done away with it is easier for heaven
and earth to pass than for one Tittle
that's the crossing of a t in the Hebrew
language
to fail it cannot be as long as there's
a heaven and the Earth is beneath your
feet and somebody tells you the Lord's
done away with you tell them you are not
telling the truth because the Earth is
still here and Heaven is still up there
next please
Pastor Brooks is the 144
000 the only ones that will be saved and
is that a literal number well first of
all the Bible in the same section read
the context in the same section John
said after this now he saw the 140 and 4
000 and they are special
and they will be translated that means
they won't die but he said after this I
saw another number that no man could
number would somebody say Amen out there
now the the the the old spiritual used
to say if I can just make it in
I don't think it matters so much which
number you're in as long as you're there
I'll be happy to be there under any
circumstances how about you next please
now which is it Pastor is it law or
Grace works or faith which is it
weren't we clear last night
let's try one more time let me let me
give you a little story I read a man
lived in a city that was bounded by a
rather wide river and people who lived
on the other side in one of the cross
the river had to walk way down to the
bridge and come across so this man got
an idea he bought himself a little boat
and he had two oars then he went and
took a hot iron and he branded 101 works
and with the other he branded in faith
and then he charged people a quarter and
across the river making a little money
and whenever he got people on his little
boat he would always turn those words so
they could see it and he'd start rowing
and they'd get out in the middle of the
river and invariably somebody would say
what do those words mean on your oars
and that's what he was waiting on
he said I'll show you and he'd pull
works up into the boat and just paddle
with Grace and Faith and you know what
happens when you pedal with one Oar you
go round and round in a circle get
nowhere
and then after a while he'd pull in
faith and he'd paddle with works and you
go around the other way
get nowhere
but when you get works and Faith
together
you can make it cross the river
ladies and gentlemen you are not saved
by works but you're not going to be
saved without words is that clear
but works follow conversion we are saved
freely but when you are saved and I hate
to use language like that because in the
Greek you have Progressive language
future perfect it really means we are
being saved and while we are being saved
it is a joy to do God's will not a
problem a privilege
the last one for the night but it's a
hard one what does the Bible say about
men who leave their families and chase
after bad women
the Bible does have a lot to say and I'm
not going to read it all to you I'm
going to the Book of Proverbs chapter 7
and verse 6. there the Bible says for at
the window of my house I look through my
casement
and be held among the simple ones what
guy
I be held among the simple ones I
discerned among the youths a young man
void of understanding and in the margin
it says lacking common sense
passing through the street near her
corner
and he went the way to her house in the
Twilight in the evening in the black and
dark night and behold I've met him a
woman with the attire of in Holland
that's the way they dress
too tight and too short and too low
the woman met him with the attire of a
harlot and subtle of heart that means
deceitful and tricky she is loud and
stubborn her feet abide not in her house
now she is without now in the streets
and liethan waited every corner so she
caught him and kissed him and with an
imputed face
trying to look romantic
with an impudent faith
said unto him I have peace offerings
with me this day have I paid my vows
therefore came our forth to meet thee
that's a lie she wanted to meet anybody
she could
therefore came our forth to meet thee
diligently to seek thy face and I have
found Thee I have decked my bed with
coverings of tapestry with carved works
with fine linen of Egypt I have perfumed
my bed
with myrrh aloes and cinnamon come let
us take our field of love until the
morning let us Solace ourselves with
love for the good man is not at home
my husband is not home
he's gone on a long journey
he took a bed a bag of money with him
and we'll come home at the day appointed
with her much fair speech she caused him
to yield
with the flattering of her lips she
forced him
he goeth after her straightway as an ox
goeth to the Florida whereas a fool to
the correction of the stocks till a DOT
strike through his liver
the good man Wasn't So Far after all
came home and caught him and drove a
switchblade
through his liver
the Bible says that man was a fool
whoever committeth adultery the Bible
says is a fool
it perverts and corrupts the mind it
destroys the home it hurts and bruises
and wounds a good woman and the thing
that amazes me is most men who do it
leave a jewel and find something that
isn't worth dragging home
and degradation and degeneracy sets in
and the minute you start it your wife
becomes unattractive
as she gets older you become more and
more critical
more and more wrinkles more and more
gray hair
she's given you her youth
but because you're fool around she
doesn't look so good now really somebody
said about a man it works with women too
same thing and there are plenty of women
who are unfaithful to their husbands and
when you start it
the devil creates a kind of excitement
and your own mate becomes unattractive
as you grow old you ought to grow up
there's never a time that a good woman
is not attractive if her husband loves
her
Pastor a young person wants to know when
God created the animals of the field did
he create dinosaurs dinosaurs
first of all God created all life
that nothing leaves that God did not
give life to
my nephew at home has a dog and that
dog's name is danger
he is a Doberman Pinscher
and he's all man
I have read quite a bit about these dogs
and a German by the name of Doberman
took a Greyhound and that Rottweiler and
he kept breeding until he got the
nobleman named after himself he did it
through cross-breeding
and he produced a work dog that was used
largely by the Germans during World War
II makes an excellent pet but he's not
really a pet he's a work dog
now I said that to say this the devil is
down here on Earth and he has
experimented with
mutations and crossbreeds and he
produced some things that are down here
I don't think God made now some things
too ugly they think they came from God
you ever look at an alligator
I just can't fit now please don't go
away sing I'm saying this
this is an opinion in my opinion is no
better than yours but I don't believe
God made all these ugly things
and when I consider how I hate a
mosquito I don't know if God ever did
that
but Satan has produced mutations sin has
affected the very things that were
created and we got a lot of these
monsters and whatever they were don't
call them prehistoric
they lived before the flood and were
destroyed by the flood because man would
become weaker and wiser and smaller and
could not go the largest animals extinct
are whales blue whales they live in the
ocean they could survive the flood
everything else died next please
Pastor another young person wants to
know is it bad or should we condemn
something because we hear it on the
radio or a cassette tape
oh no you can't condemn it like that not
a blanket condemnation no we don't mean
that at all
there are things that are on the radio
and on tapes that you shouldn't bother
with
um
well I gave you an answer the other
night I was about to say something else
and maybe I won't say it what we must
seek to do is to become personally
acquainted with Jesus
let him come into our lives and control
us and believe me
he will give you
such Impressions such new and Noble and
lofty desires that you will
automatically stop listening to what you
shouldn't listen to and you will learn
to enjoy what you should
it's not a question of is this wrong is
that wrong it's a question of being
converted then the Lord will rule you
from within and turn you off to certain
things I hope I'm being clear about that
ladies and gentlemen that's what we need
to see conversion a real real experience
with our Lord now on the other hand if
something is so close to right and so
close to wrong that you don't know what
the answer should be the Bible says in
Isaiah 8 20 to the law that's the
Commandments we've been talking about
through the law and to the testimony the
writings of the prophets to the law
written by God to the testimony written
by the prophets if they speak not
according to this word the Bible says
there is no light in them
you can test all of us including me
if I do not agree with God's law and the
writings of the Bible I'm a crook
and God allows us to do that next please
Pastor when you die will your soul go to
heaven or hell does it depend on the
kind of person that you are oh that one
got in there Wednesday night what the
ghosts Zombies and poltergeists have to
do with us today please come and listen
to that on Wednesday night now if you're
scared of ghosts bring somebody with you
here's a young person that wants to know
when did God create the months and the
seasons when did God create the months
and the seasons there are perhaps two
answers to this first of all God created
the Earth he made the sun moon and stars
the Bible says he made the son to rule
today and the moon to rule the night and
of course the Earth is moving and the
Moon is moving it is a satellite of the
earth and every time the moon comes
around again it measures off another
month so this happened automatically now
the Bible tells us that after the flood
some wondered if the world would be
destroyed Again by a flood and God gave
a rainbow and made a covenant with man
and he said while the Earth remaineth
seedtime and harvest day and night
summer and winter would not cease by the
way before the flood you did not have
severe heat and severe cold
but after the curse of the flood we have
frankly the Earth was thrown off
perpendicular the Earth tilts therefore
we have the tropics and we have the
Frozen wastes of the north land summer
and winter day and night
shall not cease After the flood they
were distinctly summer winter Autumn
spring next please all right pastor does
God punish people now if not why does he
allow illness and pain and when you beg
him over and over to take it away
ladies and gentlemen let me speak
frankly to you
it was never God's will that man should
know sickness pain and death
our for parents disobeyed God
and the curse of sin passed upon us all
I read that to you and the results of
sin are the things that you talk about
does it always mean that that particular
person sinned you remember one day Jesus
healed a blind man and the disciples
said who sinned this man or his parents
Jesus said neither
it is the condition the common lot of
humanity to suffer now you might say why
did God make God why does God make
people suffer he doesn't
don't give God credit for what the devil
does
don't blame God for what Satan
has brought upon this Earth
and much of the suffering is the result
of our cooperating with Satan you go
around drinking and smoking and taking
drugs your health will break down you
burn the candle at both ends you don't
get proper rest and you are largely
responsible for declension in health is
that clear
now why does God allow it
I would like to point something out to
you the Bible tells us that when Jesus
was here he did miracles of healing
everybody knows that
but one day he called a great apostle
one of the most outstanding of the
Apostles his name was Saul he became
Paul and Paul said he suffered from a
thorn in the flesh
and he prayed he did what
now this wasn't some drunk down in the
ghetto this was the Apostle Paul this
was Saint Paul a man who spent his life
going from place to place winning Souls
now surely wouldn't you think God would
make him well
but he prayed
and God spoke to him and told him don't
even ask me anymore
and Paul said
I rather therefore glory in my infirmity
that the Excellency might be of Christ
and not of me in other words
suffering can become God's minister
there are some people who never look up
until they're flatter their backs
I told someone today there are two
places I visit and everybody I see wants
to live right that's the jail
and the hospital
and many of them sadly say it until they
get out
then they forget all about God
but let me tell you suffering causes
people to stop thinking so much about
this world and think about their need of
Christ
many people come to God because of
suffering I don't mean take too much
time with this but don't stumble over
these things when I Pastor an enlarged
Church in Ohio there was a lady there in
a wheelchair all the time she sang She
Wrote music she was a blessing
she was paralyzed from the waist down
one day I had been out all day visiting
the sick and going from place to place
and I came home dead diet and then I
heard an announcement that almost
discouraged me someone had called and
said that this dear lady was in the
hospital
her biggest fear was that the house
would catch on fire when she was alone
and she couldn't get out
and so there she was upstairs in her
mother's home and she began to smell
something burning
and she began to fear there was no one
home
and so she decided I'll try to roll out
of bed and drag myself downstairs with
my arms and save my life and when she
threw the cover back do you know what
was burning her own leg
and she couldn't feel it because she was
paralyzed
I got in my car and drove late at night
to the big university hospital and I
went up to her room and I'm telling you
the truth I was so depressed this dear
saintly woman this happened to her on
top of everything else when I walked in
that room she was absolutely radiant
and I wasn't there long before she made
me feel better
and finally I said to her Virginia
I came up here so burdened wondering
what I could say to you and you have
lifted my bird
and with a big smile she said pastor did
you ever see that picture that my mother
has of me in the nightclub she was a
nightclub singer she was sitting at a
table and the glasses and the bottles
were on the table she said that was my
life before this accident
and now I thank God
for the accident
because now I know him as my savior
stop being discouraged don't let Satan
whip you around like that whatever
happens the Bible says Romans 8 28 all
things work together for good to them
that love the Lord and are called
according to his purpose there is
redemption in some suffering some suffer
because they're bullheaded
now Pastor you spoke on the Sabbath last
evening yes sir here's someone who says
we've always believed you should keep
every day not just one day that's the
second time I've had this question this
year that we're supposed to keep every
day holy and I remember answering it
before by saying many people most people
don't want to do what God says and then
you find someone to do more than God
said
God didn't tell us to keep every day
holy in the first place you can't keep
it holy unless it's already holy God
didn't tell us to make the day holy he's
already done that he said keep the one
holy that I mean holy now let me tell
you further a part of keeping the
Sabbath holy is not working the Bible
says
six days shall thou labor and do all thy
work but the seventh day is the Sabbath
of the Lord thy God in it Thou shalt not
do any work now if you keep every day
you won't work any day that would suit
some people just fine but then soon
start to death
don't let these
you know I have to constantly remind
myself to be careful how I speak
I'm really a nice fella
and I don't want to be caustic
but there are so many
ludicrous ideas attached to worship and
we make God's will seem like a burden
when it is simple delightful even fun
Pastor here's our last question for
tonight how did the days get their names
oh I'm glad you asked that first of all
God did not name them he only named one
he numbered them first day second day
Third Day fourth day fifth day sixth day
and then he named the one that honors
him Sabbath
say it everybody Sabbath that's the only
one he needs all the rest of them were
numbered well where did they get their
names they all came from Idols or pagan
gods Sunday because they worshiped the
son Monday because they worshiped the
moon Tuesday the god twice Wednesday
woten Thursday Thunder God Friday free
God the wife of Odin sound today after
the belted planet Saturn all were
worshiped all were idols and Mayhem
named the days god named only one and
said remember that